y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos esto es kobe 19 la
semana en américa el espacio de france
24 en el que hacemos un barrido por las
noticias más destacadas relacionadas con
la pandemia de kobe 19 a continuación
les presento algunos de los temas
destacados de este episodio
muy bien pues hablaremos con un experto
sobre la viruela del mono son varios de
los países entre ellos algunos de
américa latina que han reportado casos
de esta enfermedad es una nueva amenaza
desde la prevención que debemos tener en
cuenta y que la diferencia de la viruela
común en unos minutos les vamos a contar
más también hablaremos de el panorama
general que hay en eeuu y en canadá
países en donde vamos a tratar el número
de casos de contagio de kobe 19 si están
en aumento o de creciendo qué medidas
están tomando las autoridades y que se
mantiene en cuanto a los planes de
vacunación y a las altas o bajas tasas
de vacunación que están presentando
altas por lo menos en canadá también les
preguntaremos a nuestros corresponsales
qué medidas están tomando los gobiernos
de estos países frente a la aparición de
algunos casos de la viruela del mono y
también hablaremos de la isla de rapa
nui o isla de pascua en chile que
anunció la reapertura a partir del
primero de agosto dos años y medio de
aislamiento dejaron a la economía de
esta isla basada completamente en el
turismo seriamente afectada pero también
dejó grandes lecciones en cuanto los
valores y las formas de subsistencia
ancestrales conversamos con pedro pablo
es mucha para él es el alcalde de la
isla de pascua quien nos va a dar un
mayor detalle de ese plan escalonado de
apertura pues comenzamos entonces y como
lo decíamos pues siguen aumentando los
números de casos de viruela del mundo
diferentes países del mundo europa
puntualmente se está convirtiendo en el
continente con la mayor cantidad de
casos siendo el reino unido portugal y
españa los países con la mayor cantidad
de casos todos leves sin fallecidos
hasta el momento pero vamos a ver
entonces cómo están las cifras hay hasta
el momento 219 casos reportados en todo
el mundo además de los casos en donde
esta enfermedad ya es endémica que eso
sucede en varios países africanos 19
países han reportado casos alrededor del
mundo en américa en nuestro continente
eeuu 9 y argentina es el primer país
latinoamericano con solamente un caso
reportado hasta el momento son cifras
que son entregadas por el centro europeo
de prevención y control de enfermedades
hoy vamos a profundizar en este tema
está con nosotros daniel lópez acuña el
epidemiólogo también ex director de la
acción sanitaria de la organización
mundial de la salud lado ms está con
nosotros se conecta desde la ciudad de
gijón en españa' señor lópez bienvenidos
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
kobe 19 la semana en américa y señor
lópez pues ya lo decíamos hay un aumento
de casos principalmente en europa
podemos hablar de una amenaza global de
esta enfermedad que está creciendo en
cuanto a casos le pregunto porque el
portavoz precisamente de la sociedad
española de médicos generales y familia
lorenzo armenteros no descarta
infecciones masivas así lo dijo en
algunas declaraciones a medios españoles
mire desde un punto de vista
epidemiológico que estamos ante una
enfermedad que está presentando un
número mayor de casos que el que
habitualmente se observa especialmente
en países no endémicos pero no estamos
ante una amenaza social de una pandemia
estamos ante un fenómeno que debe
desatar la alerta epidemiológica para
poder diagnosticar precozmente aislar a
los casos y controlar el brote pero no
debemos
alimentar un temor o un miedo social a
que tengamos una situación en donde
estemos entrando en una nueva pandemia
perfecto importante esa claridad y
entender que esto es parte de los
protocolos precisamente para hacer
frente a ese número de casos que se está
presentando así las corre señor lópez
entonces cuáles son los tratamientos
cuáles son las formas de prevenir el
contagio de esta viruela del mono
bueno lo lo primero es entender que no
es una enfermedad nueva sino que es una
enfermedad que se conoce desde 1958 el
virus y diseminados en 70 el primer caso
en la república democrática del congo es
fundamentalmente una enfermedad que está
presente en animales roedores y simic y
que excepcionalmente da el salto hacia
humanos y produce casos que son raros en
áfrica occidental y en cualquier caso
sigue siendo un fenómeno endémica la
transmisión se da fundamentalmente por
contactos estrechos por intercambio de
fluidos corporales muy especialmente por
contacto con el líquido que emana de las
vesículas que se forman pero también por
cualquier líquido o fluido corporal como
saliva semen sangre que puede generar
este contagio e incluso podemos tener un
contagio por contaminación de sábanas o
toallas con los fluidos que emanan de
estas vesículas cuando no están
debidamente lavada no ha habido la
higiene del caso entonces estamos ante
una transmisión que no es como la del
cob y que no está ocurriendo
simplemente por aerosoles en suspensión
en espacios cerrados o en un ascensor o
en un evento
masivo en donde no se pueda tener
protección sino que se trata de
contactos estrechos seguir donde hay
intercambio de fluidos corporales
importante saber esto para precisamente
determinar mecanismos de prevención
señor lópez para terminar y hablando
específicamente de enfermedades no
solamente de esta viruela del mono da la
impresión que ahora los virus son tal
vez más agresivos antes en décadas atrás
no veíamos casos por ejemplo esta
viruela del mono en países europeos o en
países de áfrica por lo menos tantos
casos en tan poco tiempo se debe algún
factor en particular que los virus estén
como siendo un poco más agresivos o
puedan tener la facilidad de montar y
desarrollar variantes y sus variantes
más rápido como ha pasado con el hobby
miren el caso de la viruela del bono en
los estudios hasta ahora hechos muestran
que no hay una mutación o una generación
de una variante distinta no ha habido un
cambio genético la secuenciación ha
mostrado que es la misma cepa que hay en
el áfrica occidental por fortuna menos
virulenta que la de la república
democrática del congo lo que tenemos es
más trasiego de personas más
intercambios más viajes y en el caso
específicamente de la viruela del mono
en europa y muy particularmente en
españa ha habido algunos eventos súper
propagadores o super contagia dores que
han acelerado la interacción cercana de
personas y esto ha generado un número
importante de casos lo importante es
detener los brotes con diagnóstico con
aislamiento de los casos y con un
seguimiento y rastreo muy estrecho de
los contactos señor lópez pues creo que
nos da un parte de tranquilidad muchas
gracias por aclararnos estas dudas
frente a esta viruela del mono esta
enfermedad muchísimas gracias a usted
allí en españa' bueno y vamos a hablar
ahora de algunas cifras veamos entonces
cómo está el avance de la pandemia de
kobe 19 el cierre de esta semana veremos
cifras de los últimos 28 días en
diferentes países comenzamos en mexico
en donde en los últimos 28 días han
reportado unos 21 mil 962 casos nuevos
de contagio y han fallecido 514 personas
en la isla de cuba en los últimos 28
días han sido reportados unos 2500 77
casos y hay 4 personas reportadas como
fallecidas vamos un poco más al sur
vamos hasta paraguay los casos superan
ya los 1290 personas han fallecido en
estos últimos 28 días y terminamos en
uruguay la república oriental reporta 20
mil 600 casos en los últimos 28 días y
los fallecidos llegan a 30
bueno y una vez más los contagios por
kobe 19 están en aumento en el mundo lo
hemos venido diciendo en las últimas
semanas los expertos lo atribuyen al
surgimiento de sus variantes derivadas
de la variante omicron que resultan ser
mucho más contagiosas veamos el panorama
la pandemia de koi 19 no ha terminado el
auto over anywhere nos acaba en ninguna
parte hasta que se acabe en todas partes
los casos notificados están aumentando
en casi 70 países de todas las regiones
y esto en un mundo en el que los índices
de pruebas han caído en picada hub
planet en eeuu por ejemplo se espera un
rebrote dentro de las próximas cuatro
semanas mientras que california informó
de una media de 11 mil 200 casos diarios
en la última semana una cifra que
duplica los casos de las tres semanas
anteriores y que a su vez es más de
cinco veces superior al mínimo reciente
de unos dos mil cien casos diarios a
finales de marzo
y
nuestra incapacidad para vacunar
completamente a nuestro país ha
permitido que omicron se extienda con
más fuerza puede que ahora estemos
logrando la inmunidad de rebaño pero no
de la manera que queríamos queremos
conseguirla a través de la vacunación y
ahora la estamos consiguiendo con un
terrible precio de enfermedad e incluso
muerte
a través de la sal y verdad en efecto el
doctor hachís ya coordinador de la lucha
contra el coronavirus de la casa blanca
considera que eeuu podría verse obligado
a ceder muchos de los avances logrados
en los últimos dos años y advirtió de la
posibilidad de que los más vulnerables
sufran escasez de suministros ya que el
país ha gastado casi todo el dinero del
plan de rescate de 1900 millones de
dólares que se dedicaba directamente a
la respuesta al cob y 19 entretanto el
país norteamericano espera una decisión
de la fd a la administración de
alimentos y medicamentos de eeuu sobre
la autorización de la vacuna de las
farmacéuticas modernas para niños
menores de cinco años y de facer para
los menores de cuatro y sabes que el
comité es un riesgo real para los niños
más pequeños no conocemos los riesgos a
largo plazo y eso como madre es lo que
se me queda grabado en la mente así que
a medida que sabemos más y más sobre los
posibles riesgos de largo plazo de coach
para los niños me gustaría no tener que
preocuparme de que enfermen gravemente o
tengan estos efectos a largo plazo
eeuu es el país que más contagios y más
decesos ha registrado porque hoy 19 en
el mundo más de un millón de personas
han fallecido a causa del virus en este
territorio lo que equivale a toda la
población de san francisco y según la
casa blanca más de 200 mil niños en eeuu
han perdido a uno de sus padres oa su
acudiente a causa del virus
ya les decía al inicio del programa
vamos a hacer énfasis en eeuu y en
canadá países en los que necesitamos
saber cómo está la situación vamos
entonces hasta miami allí se encuentra
antoni belchí para conocer cómo está el
número de contagios la hospitalización
los casos de contagio aumento en eeuu y
sobre todo esos puntos esos estados o
ciudades puntuales en donde el panorama
es más complicado adelante antonio
hola santiago pues si las autoridades
sanitarias en eeuu siguen monitoreando
una nueva versión de coronavirus que
ahora es la dominante en el país
pertenece a la familia de omicron pero
ya los científicos han asegurado que se
propaga mucho más rápido que las otras
cepas lo más peligroso es que es capaz
de eludir la inmunidad de las vacunas y
los científicos temen que pueda causar
un cuadro mucho más grave el problema
también es que esta nueva variante
combina propiedades tanto de omicron
como de la variante delta que en un
momento del año pasado también se
convirtió en la mutación más dominante
del país está su variante se ha
encontrado en el 58 por ciento de los
casos de kobe 19 de la semana pasada y
según datos oficiales los casos de
coronavirus han empezado a subir de
nuevo también las muertes es por eso que
ahora se teme que haya una nueva ola de
contagios los médicos sin embargo
aseguran que aún es muy pronto para
pronosticar un aumento de casos
generalizados por coronavirus y piden
que en la medida de lo posible se
mantengan las recomendaciones que se
impusieron en el inicio de la pandemia
utilizar mascarilla en caso de sospecha
evitar grandes aglomeraciones y
vacunarse aunque sí ya muchos aquí en
eeuu hacen caso omiso a esto y porque
hay un clima de confianza al pensar que
la pandemia ha terminado aunque no es
así santiago
antonio cómo está avanzando la
vacunación en eeuu
pues la vacunación en eeuu sigue
prácticamente estancada lo hace a un
ritmo muy lento se estima que el 78 por
ciento de la población se ha puesto al
menos una dosis el 67 por ciento tiene
la pauta completa de vacunación y poco
más del 30 por ciento la dosis de
refuerzo como hemos dicho el coronavirus
parece volverse más infeccioso con cada
nueva variante y con la disminución de
la inmunidad con el paso de los meses el
gobierno de bailén ha pronosticado que
hasta 100 millones de personas podrían
contagiarse de kobe 19 entre otoño e
invierno por eso desde la casa blanca
intentan promover la dosis de refuerzo
aunque ya se retiraron todos los fondos
públicos para sufragar los gastos de las
pruebas de coronavirus y también de las
vacunas by then ha pedido que se vuelvan
a destinar ayudas económicas porque
muchos al no poder pagar los seguros
médicos no van a poder ponerse las
vacunas y la situación podría empeorar a
finales de año de todos modos o muchos
creen que no es necesario ponerse la
vacuna de refuerzo sobre todo si tenemos
en cuenta los bajos datos de vacunación
ese poco más del 30 por ciento de la
población
puesto una tercera dosis de la vacuna
por eso muchos desconfían en que los
estadounidenses quieran ponerse una
cuarto o incluso una quinta dosis como
incluso ya se baraja antonio finalizó
preguntándole por los casos de viruela
del mono registrados en eeuu que dicen
las autoridades allí
pues santiago hasta el momento los
centros para el control y la prevención
de enfermedades de eeuu los cdc han
identificado al menos nueve casos de la
viruela del mono se han identificado en
siete estados aquí en florida pero
también en massachusetts just you time
washington california virginia y nueva
york- desde el organismo sanitario
encargado de monitorear este virus
confirmaron que todos son hombres
homosexuales bisexuales y hombres que
han tenido relaciones sexuales con otros
hombres aunque recalcan que estas
conclusiones deben ser adoptadas con un
enfoque guiado por la ciencia y no por
el estigma y la discriminación que ahora
podrían sufrir algunos miembros de la
comunidad lgtb tecum al mismo tiempo los
cdc están trabajando para obtener más
información sobre el brote las muestras
de los nueve casos identificados se han
enviado a los laboratorios para realizar
pruebas confirmatorias adicionales e
investigaciones genómicas también se
está tratando de saber cómo contrajo el
virus cada individuo a algunos de los
nueve casos tienen un historial reciente
de viajes internacionales a zonas con
brotes activos de la viruela pero otros
no eeuu se espera que se diagnostiquen
en más casos ya que los cdc han instado
a los médicos y a los estadounidenses a
estar atentos a los síntomas santiago
muchas gracias.antonio por este reporte
desde la ciudad de miami hablamos ahora
de la vacunación que sigue avanzando en
nuestro continente veamos cómo termina
entonces la semana un grupo de países de
nuestro continente países al azar vamos
a ver el número de dosis de refuerzo
inoculadas por cada 100 habitantes
comenzamos en mexico 40 puntos 69 dosis
de refuerzo por cada 100 habitantes para
más llega a 36 punto 52 dosis de
refuerzo perú el número ya se incrementa
hasta 53 punto 48 dosis por cada 100
habitantes chile llega a 109 punto 57
por cada dosis por cada 100 habitantes
y es momento para nuestra habitual
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo y también
asesor científico de france 24 a quien
saludamos en la ciudad de bogotá doctor
pérez un gusto tenerlo en el programa
como siempre y comienzo preguntándole
por los cortes en los procesos de
vacunación de los planes de vacunación
en los diferentes países es un tema que
hemos ido abordando a lo largo de estos
años aquí en el programa i 7m entonces
que en unos meses haya brotes de otro
tipo de enfermedades como por ejemplo
sarampión y cito esta enfermedad porque
ya autoridades a nivel mundial han
alertado por posibles brotes de este de
esta enfermedad en países de américa
latina'
si santiago lo que es importante tener
en cuenta es que la vacunación que
nosotros hacemos habitualmente para
nuestros niños para los adultos se
mantener lo que se ha visto es que por
la situación de la pandemia por
disposición de biológicos por
situaciones de cada país no se está
llevando a cabo los planes de vacunación
que vienen funcionando hace muchos años
y eso hace que haya una emergencia y que
enfermedades como el sarampión o la tos
ferina pudieran incrementarse en el
tiempo por eso el llamado es a vacunar a
nuestros niños a mantener los servicios
de vacunación ya volver a los centros de
salud para activar toda la medicina
preventiva que nos ha fallado o que no
hemos hecho en estos dos últimos años el
doctor hablemos ahora de el coronavirus
el cob el 19 en la fauna salvaje lo
pregunto porque hay alerta en brasil
porque la comunidad científica de este
país detectó algunos casos en algunos
animales puntualmente que se sabe que se
comenta en la comunidad científica sobre
esto
santiago y como decía el invitado que
teníamos al principio del programa la
importancia que tiene determinar que sea
una sonó sis recordemos que una
enfermedad sonó tica es cuando se
transmite del animal al hombre pero
cuando el hombre también puede infectar
al animal en dentro de la fauna pueden
hacer recambios el virus y puede
infectar o hacer sub linajes que puede
afectarnos a nosotros entonces en ese
momento y por esa razón debemos
monitorizar tanto el comportamiento de
los animales como el comportamiento en
los humanos lo que se ha encontrado en
brasil es que algunas de su fauna que es
muy extensa en brasil tienen el sars no
es que se hayan enfermado estos animales
y está en evaluación esa posibilidad de
recombinación y que infecte nuevamente a
los humanos hay que mantener las medidas
de monitoreo epidemiológica en estas
poblaciones doctor pérez volvemos a esta
debate de las vacunas la unión europea
dice que tal vez no sea necesaria una
cuarta dosis en suecia el gobierno de
este país dice que va a ser necesaria
una quinta dosis para personas que
tengan complicaciones o enfermedades
preexistentes
desde su perspectiva y cuál es la mejor
versión para nosotros para seguir
combatiendo el kobe 19 una cuarta dosis
una quinta dosis vacunaciones periódicas
hasta que la enfermedad se vuelva
endémica
la enfermedad se está comportando
endémicamente gracias a los procesos de
vacunación lo que no hay ninguna duda es
que se necesitan la pauta completa más
un refuerzo es decir al menos tres dosis
y cuando se usa la vacuna jansen al
menos 22 la cuarta dosis está digamos
con bastante evidencia sobre todo en
poblaciones mayores de 50 años y con
riesgo una quinta unas estados y solo lo
vamos a saber cuando tengamos exámenes
de laboratorio que nos permitan saber
qué persona está en múnich qué persona
no está inmune para poder determinar el
proceso de revacunación eso se va a
tomar un tiempo cuál es la recomendación
si no sea si no se ha reforzado refuerce
se hila y donde esté disponible la
cuarta dosis hay que hacerlo es muy
probablemente que una quinta unas
estados y no sean periódicamente de seis
meses sean anualmente y que sean con
otros biológicos entonces tenemos que
estar pendiente de esa información en
estos próximos meses doctor muchas
gracias reiteramos siempre aquí en este
programa la necesidad de la vacunación
como arma para seguir combatiendo el
kobe 19 muchísimas gracias doctor pérez
a lo largo de estos dos años y medio
hemos seguido la situación en rapa nui
en la isla de pascua esta isla de casas
y está a casi cuatro mil kilómetros de
distancia de la costa chilena y decidió
aislarse del mundo casi por completo
como una forma de escudo contra el jove
19 el turismo desapareció por completo
el comercio con chile continental
disminuyó considerablemente y los
habitantes regresaron a actividades como
la pesca el cultivo de alimentos de
subsistencia dos años y medio después el
gobierno anunció la reapertura y para
conocer detalles de este proceso de
apertura de esta isla hasta con nosotros
el alcalde de rapa nui y el señor pedro
paulo edmón supo a quién nos atiende
desde agarró a la capital de esta isla
en el pacífico señor alcalde dos años y
medio cerrados ya se espera que en
agosto pues comienza esta apertura como
va a ser el plan en qué consiste este
plan de apertura bienvenido al programa
bueno yo
primero que todo agradecer esta
instancia para una vez más hablarle a
ustedes y a través de ustedes al mundo
al planeta rafa no hoy en la isla más
aisladas del mundo y no estaba aislado
más aún con el móvil por dos años y
medio ya
efectivamente se tomó la decisión de
oficialmente de abrir al turismo y a
vuelos comerciales a partir del primero
de agosto
eso ha sido anunciado por nuestro
gobierno del presidente boris y hay un
equipo multidisciplinario trabajando
para que esa apertura sea de forma
responsable y segura nuestro contexto de
responsable y segura nosotros ya
iniciamos
el levante de la restricción
básicamente la restricción tiene que ver
con un elemento que es
y otra hora
facultad que exigía una cuarentena de
cinco días
hoy día ya no está esa exigencia
y estamos probando por eso es una
apertura responsable paso a paso y ya
estamos probando ya llevamos dos vuelos
una vez a la semana con los pasajeros
que llegan que son todos residentes
porque aún no está abierto hasta agosto
para lo que es comercial y turismo sin
embargo estamos probando con los mismos
residentes que están en santiago de
chile que cuando ingresan ingresan sin
la cuarentena pero con todas las otras
restricciones vigentes
alcalde esta es una isla que vive del
turismo y estuvo cerrada al público dos
años y medio como se vio afectada la
economía pascuense
bueno estos dos años de cierre ha dejado
a la isla sin economía ha dejado a la
isla en una en una situación de pobreza
jamás sentida jamás vista de
entonces hoy día la isla está viviendo
de lo que nosotros localmente producimos
de lo que pescamos o sea lo que hicimos
acá a santiago es volver a la usanza
ancestral
como vivían nuestros ancestros y eso lo
que estamos haciendo hoy día estamos
sustentando los
esperando entonces que vuelva a la
economía nuestra economía es 100%
turismo entonces
bueno es sabido de djokovic
19 ha pegado duro a esta industria y la
rapa nui no es ajeno a ella entonces la
situación económica es muy muy triste
muy mala
yo lo vivo todos los días prácticamente
soy el único gobierno en este territorio
que se le presta hombro que le presta
oído
y escucha a la gente porque no tenemos
no tenemos otra manera de resolver
problemas a 4000 kilómetros de distancia
de nuestro estado
alcalde hay aproximadamente un 73% de la
población ya ha vacunado prácticamente
no hay casos de kobe 19 solamente hay un
pequeño hospital en hanga roa la capital
es un es muy difícil mantener ese
equilibrio sanitario en un entorno tan
aislado y tan pequeño están ustedes
satisfechos con estas condiciones para
poder dar apertura a la llegada de
turistas no solamente de chiles sino de
todas partes del mundo
mira a santiago en estos dos años y
medio
sí principado rápidamente es sintetizar
los dos años y medio el primer año 2020
no teníamos la vacuna y igual nosotros
teníamos una vez a la semana un vuelo
que
que conectaba a la mano y con con chile
continental dentro de eso de esos
periodos nosotros trasladamos mucha
gente
en resumen entre marzo del 2020 y en la
semana pasada la línea aérea en conjunto
con nosotros hemos trasladado a más de
8.500 personas y esas personas ningún
caso de contagio y por qué porque fuimos
muy estricto en
las reglas de autocuidado tiene que ser
el medio desde el puerto de entrada que
en este caso santiago de chile
y comenzar a fiscalizar quienes se suben
o quienes llegan al aeropuerto tienen
que llegar
con sus psr 48 horas antes de forma
negativa y aún así en el aeropuerto se
ha tomado todas las medidas para que no
existan los contagios y llegando a rapa
nui en rábano y hemos sido muy estricto
en hacer la trazabilidad de forma tal de
que en ningún caso se pueda suscitar o
aflorar en los valores eso nos llevó a
nosotros a garantizar los dos años y
medio que llevamos de tránsito de
personas en menor cantidad por supuesto
pero el tránsito fin y al cabo sin
ningún caso es móvil esa misma
experiencia queremos trasladarlo al
turismo
queremos que el turismo que llegue a
rapa nui venga con los mismos protocolos
que hoy día le estamos exigiendo a
nuestros propios residentes pero además
acompañado de una inversión que el
estado tiene que hacer o sea que no lo
ha hecho aún y tiene que hacer esa
inversión en el hospital local para
garantizar aquella situación que pueda
suscitar de contagio y que pueda ser
contenida
muy bien sabemos de que si si tenemos el
80 o sobre el 80 de vacunación ya el
margen de riesgo se minimiza a un 20
quizás a un 15% en esos márgenes estamos
trabajando
la cifra que me acaba de decir 73% tiene
que ver con la vacunación de refuerzo
eso quiere decir que sobre el 80% de la
comunidad está con primera segunda dosis
sea sobre el 80% de la población ya
tiene la inmunización del cob y lo que
nos está faltando son los de refuerzos y
es obvio que el porcentaje tiene que ser
menor porque muchas de estas personas se
vacunaron recién ahí en enero febrero
marzo de este año por lo tanto el
periodo de tiempo para lograr llegar al
80 por ciento refuerzo todavía falta y
creo creemos nosotros que vamos a llegar
a fines de julio con sobre el 80% de
vacunación y eso nos da también un
margen de seguridad para mover
tranquilo la economía al alcalde ustedes
están a cinco horas de vuelo desde
santiago la capital de chile y la isla
más cercana está haití a otras 5 horas
de vuelo el aislamiento ha sido
prácticamente parte de la vida de los
pascuenses pero es cerrarse al mundo eso
sí fue una actividad completamente
distinta y cambió por completo la
dinámica de la isla cómo está la
sociedad para secuencia cómo está la
salud mental de los ciudadanos cómo
están los isleños
santiago lo que puedo comunicarle
y por qué interactúo con toda la
comunidad con muchos programas que
nosotros hemos llevado a cabo es que la
comunidad como que se reencontró con sus
raíces se reencontró con su propósito
cosa que antes de la pandemia lo que
hacíamos era servirle al western todos
los días entonces era era una cosa muy
impersonal y la cuestión del propósito
ancestral quedó encapsulado en un
producto turístico para comercializar
con este encierro nos dimos cuenta el
error por décadas que nosotros hicimos
con nuestros valores ancestrales de
encapsular lo en un producto turístico y
hoy día la comunidad
muy llana a
dejar de hacer esa forma de trabajar y
resaltar más los valores ancestrales que
son los que nos ayudó a cuidar estos dos
años nos ayudó a protegernos a todos
años una de ellas el tapón el tapón es
un valor ancestral que tiene que ver con
respetar tu entorno respetarte a ti
mismo respetar a los otros y cumplir las
reglas el otro valor tiene que ver con
el modo en moa es el respeto respeta que
a ti mismo respeta a tus vecinos respeto
a tus hijos tu familia y respeta el
entorno porque eso te alimenta te cuida
el otro valor tiene que ver
con román karma y significa perdón
disculpa asuma si te sucede a ti asuma
la corresponsabilidad
aprenda de esa sabiduría y devuelve los
a los otros en forma de que el otro
pueda también
entenderlo y pueda colaborar y por
último el otro valor tiene que ver con
humana humana es es un valor ancestral
antiquísimo de que si yo tengo yo lo
comparto lo comparto contigo si tú
tienes algo distinto lo compartes
conmigo y entre los dos hacemos
abundancia y compartimos con el otro y
así hemos hecho con toda la comunidad al
no tener dinero al no tener economía
tuvimos que acudir a esos valores
ancestrales para tener los productos y
tener un alimento básico de sustento y
tener una animosidad en una suerte
medianamente tranquila porque no hay que
olvidar de guerra pan hoy es mitad a
rapa nui de origen étnico rapa nui y la
otra mitad es
importado son extranjeros europeos
extranjeros chilenos continentales
latinoamericanos asiáticos hay de todo
un poco que están casados con nosotros
el enriquecimiento cultural pero también
que trae una contradicción a la cultura
original y aquí en estos dos años
podemos volver a sacar a flote estos
conceptos ancestrales de la
sustentabilidad y del sobretodo santiago
del respeto y eso ha sido muy valorado a
la comunidad hasta ahora
alcalde edmons creo que es un caso único
lo que ha vivido la isla de pascua a lo
largo de esta pandemia kobe 19 muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
vamos a pasar ahora a canadá a otro país
que teníamos para hacer el foco en este
episodio vamos a ver cómo está la
situación allí conectamos entonces en
montreal o la ciudad de montreal en
quebec con la periodista carolina villa
media que ahora link a muchas gracias
por estar con nosotros y comencemos
entonces por conocer cómo es la
situación de canadá en cuanto a
contagios personas vacunadas y
fallecidos
si bien la pandemia todavía no acaba la
tendencia en el número de contagios en
el número de hospitalizaciones y de
muertes es hacia la baja hacia una lenta
y progresiva estabilización así lo han
dejado saber las autoridades del país la
última semana el porcentaje de tex
positivos para 2019 fue del 11% y hasta
el momento canadá ha tenido tres
millones 860 mil casos desde el inicio
de la pandemia si observamos las
provincias que tienen mayor población
son la provincia ontario y la provincia
de québec actualmente un 42 por ciento
de las hospitalizaciones en ontario son
por kobe 19 y un 58% se debe a otras
razones en quebec comparando los datos
con los de la semana anterior esta
semana ha habido una reducción de 24 por
ciento en el número de contagios 14 por
ciento en el número de hospitalizaciones
y 29% en el el caso de las personas en
cuidados intensivos lo que nos muestra
una clara tendencia a la estabilización
y al descenso en estas cifras que en
algún momento fueron muy alarmantes
carolina le pregunto ahora por los casos
de viruela del mono en canadá han
registrado aproximadamente unos 15 casos
como están sorteando la situación que
dicen las autoridades
según las últimas cifras oficiales
ofrecidas por las autoridades del país
ya son 26 casos de viruela del mono en
canadá la mayoría de estos casos se han
producido en la provincia francófona de
quebec 25 casos para ser concretos y la
mayoría de ellos en la ciudad más grande
de la provincia que es la metrópolis de
montreal también se ha producido otro
caso en contra de las provincias más
grandes las de mayor población de canadá
que es la provincia de ontario las
autoridades de quebec se han movilizado
rápidamente y han anunciado que a partir
de este viernes todas las personas que
han tenido un contacto directo que han
estado expuestas a este virus a través
de alguna persona contagiada pueden
acceder a la vacunación y aquí han dicho
que esta vacunación debería darse
idealmente en los cuatro días siguientes
a que se haya producido este contacto
igualmente las autoridades del país y
las autoridades de quebec han dicho que
esta situación no puede compararse a la
pandemia que hemos vivido en estos
últimos dos años pero que hay que
movilizarse rápidamente y tomar medidas
para evitar una potencial explosión
bueno de 20 casos allí en canadá
carolina villamediana reportando nos
desde montreal muchas gracias carolina y
así llegamos al final del programa sigan
con la programación de france 24
[Música]